120 thousand people here at the United
Nations climate conference in Paris and
it all comes down to this a 48-page
draft agreement a lot of people are
confused about what's inside I'm going
to go look for an explanation from
somebody who knows what they're talking
about
are you doing good how are you there's
two pieces to this agreement and I want
you to walk me through the two pieces
what everyone's talking about is the
agreement itself that's this document
this is the rock that we need to finish
here it's a set of articles and
principles and concepts of how we're
going to deal with climate change for
the next 20 years this becomes the
entire basis of how the world deals with
climate change if we get the Paris
agreement it's the most ambitious
international environmental agreement of
this generation but to make that work
you got the agreement then you have to
breathe life into it you have to cloak
it with decisions and finance and more
particular information and that's the
part of the discussions here called the
decisions so we've got the Paris
agreement that is a rock and then we've
got a set of decisions that throw the
rock or move the rock or roll the rock
or stop the rock but the decisions bring
life to that agreement so what goes in
the agreement and what goes in the
decision is that's a matter of
negotiations but in principle the
agreement can be changed in the future
but it's very unlikely so if you want it
to last decisions breathe life to it but
decisions can change so we want as much
specifics ambitious information in the
agreement but if it's contentious during
the negotiations here or they're not
able to get compromised they still need
to get this across the line so they'll
move some of the decision making and
some of the arguing and compromises out
of the core agreements a rock and move
it into the decisions because right now
we've got you know 150 paragraphs of
decisions and if they can't get to an
agreement what they
can do is just say we didn't get to an
agreement will start this conversation
next year but we still needs a rock to
be developed here and passed by all
parties all countries on earth we are a
long way from an agreement here the
political will is here but there are
still hundreds of legal decisions to
have to be translated across six
languages that have to do with some of
the most contentious issues on earth
those still need to be resolved right so
you know in terms of negotiations I
teach at university of california's you
know like for the midterm countries
would have gotten a B+ but you can still
get an F for the course if you don't
show up to the final exam like right
we're not there yet right right so we're
hoping that the agreement will be as
ambitious as possible and we also hope
the decisions will be as ambitious as
possible